Oh wait, you're listening.
[inaudible]
okay. We're listening to
radio lab radio way too.
[inaudible]
awesome. New York public
radio. Public radio. W
[inaudible] radio.
Sure.
Okay. Okay. So the um, the other day,
I bet. Should we say we are? Yes, we
should. Okay. Jad Robert Radiolab.
Okay. So the other day Soren called
us into the studio. They are,
oh.
And there was a giant human sized
Roden sitting in the engineering seat.
Very large road.
And it was very familiar to us because
it was a puppet head that we had toured
with. Who is that under that big
street and well that's the question.
That is the question maybe you guys
should guess or something. Oh my goodness.
Is it, um, is this Helen? Oh my God.
Oh my God. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
all right.
So the story is the reason that snoring
got Ellen to surprise us is that
somewhere around now is the
15 year crazy to say it.
15 year anniversary of making radio
lab. 15 years. I know we were,
have some tape for you guys. Oh,
there's more, right? We brought,
you said it's just your presence.
Yeah, I mean the presence,
I mean it seemed like you gotta have
someone around who knew you when you know,
okay, perfect audience with my
presence. So we sort of settled in.
We didn't really know what was going on
and then horn did something truly evil.
She somehow,
I don't know how probably the archivist
help got her hands on the very first
one. This is my nightmare. The very,
very, very, I had hoped these
tapes and that would never surface,
but she found them.
They were on bit torrent for a second
and I thought they had disappeared and I
was like so happy. But then
[inaudible] already yet it's okay.
Let me rotate. All right, here we go.
2002 very first one. Okay. Don't start
talking. Please make the CD crash.
Right now.
Every radio producer has this
idealized image in their head of you.
Oh God. Maybe you're sitting
on the couch drinking coffee,
staring out the window.
Maybe you're the person who's driving and
you pull over to really concentrate on
a story. Whenever the case,
that image in the radio producers
brain of you, the listener,
that's why they make this
stuff still only thing. Yeah,
they don't get paid much.
And you look around these heavy recorders
and mikes and they look frankly silly
in those headphones. I have to wear it,
but it doesn't matter as long as you
are there to listen to what they make.
W N Y C is about to
embark on an experiment.
We're calling it the
radio lab and love that.
We're going to do great documentary
radio and stories of different sizes and
shapes,
colors from different places all over
the planet from different times even.
And we're going to mix it
all together like this.
Whoa. Wait,
the big brew of people and places,
but it'll take two hours and
59 minutes to get through.
Oh, two hours, 15 minutes,
two hours, three hours.
It was a three hour show and was I
that was that every week, by the way.
Every freaking week. Every week.
Eight to 11 every Sunday night.
So they were giving you
a huge hunk of airtime,
a huge hunk of airtime
where no one was listening.
Javelin rod here I'll be your,
hmm, host is not the right
word. Curator guide maybe.
How about DJ of documentary?
Oh shut up. That was really terrible.
That doesn't work at all.
Every moment of that was robbed.
Every moment I have to explain like this
show is just super different back then.
The idea of it back then was to just take
all of these documentaries from around
the world and smashed them together.
But what would end up happening is
that like I would line up three or four
things and I would have
like a 20 minute hole,
which I would start to experiment in.
And that's those spots were what
the show grew out of. Well, so,
so that was in 2002 and then I met you
the following spring and then a year
later, a whole year later. And
so there's a year worth of that.
And by the time I met
you back in New York,
you were so sleep deprived. Okay.
So we reminisced for a little bit.
And then we started talking about
the moment when Robert got involved,
which is a moment I'll never
forget. So, um, you know,
I was trying to fill one
of those 20 minute holes.
I had done an interview with a memory
researcher and it was just one of those
signs,
interviews that now we're super familiar
with where like the scientist is using
all this latinate words and I couldn't
figure out what she was saying,
but it still seemed interesting.
I just couldn't understand it.
And so a Robert and Ellen and I had
breakfast one day at Kitchenette,
our foundation restaurant, that's where
you go to for breakfast every week.
And we were sitting there and I
was like, I got this interview.
I don't really know what to do.
It's about memory and here's
what I think she's saying.
I think she's saying something about
how memories are never the same.
You're always constantly remaking them.
And then you just like snapped into
this thing where like suddenly you were
playing this like all these
characters and w l and I were like,
oh my God, let's just go into the studio
and have do that and you want to hear
a little taste of that time. I'm
sort of curious what we, this was,
this was one.
So the one like we later did the
memory and forgetting as a podcast,
but this is pre, this is before.
That is a diff earlier 2003 I think.
[inaudible]
you're listening to radio
lab on New York public radio,
public radio w and the
Jab. I'm Ron. This is radio lab. We're
coming up on the Kitty Hawk centennial,
the hundredth anniversary of
the first human powered flight.
It's in a couple of weeks and I was
looking at the picture today. No,
you weren't the Wright brothers. You
know the one Oroville is on the plane.
It's just taking off. Wilbur is
running alongside there on a beach.
The beach is deserted. It looks really,
really cold and I'm looking at this photo.
Really noticed the most published
picture in the history of pictures.
What are the collateral?
Even though I have anyone who's ever
been born as seen it 100,000 times,
I couldn't help but be wowed.
I mean, look what they did.
They got their crazy box into the air a
couple hundred feet or whatever it was.
Wasn't that great a
distance, but look at us now.
We can fly over the Atlantic in
five hours, a few hundred dollars
and that is not what we're going to talk
about today because my real question is
how is it we can do all that and still
not understand some very basic things
like common cold. That's the
example that's always given.
What about memory?
What about memory? Is that what she
used? [inaudible] that's a good intro.
Every, how's a minute? 30 wow.
That's sort of like, well
here's the pogo stick.
I'm going to jump on it 50
times. But what about tissues?
It's such a good idea to wait to get in.
We eventually talk about Kitty Hawk
or was that just, oh no, but let's,
let's go a little bit further forward so
we get to hear Robert enter the room 18
Volvo's creativity.
This club actually begins with a reading
from theater director and actor Simon
McBurney. You have to
literally remake it every time.
Every memory that you
remember is different because
it is we made in the very
present that you remember another
words in order to remember,
you need the imagination.
[inaudible]
Simon McBurney performing a monologue
from is playing pneumonic for the show
studio three 60.
And with me in the studio to explore
these ideas a little further.
Is Mr Robert Krulwich from
ABC News or Robert Height,
you've reported on this,
right? Yeah, they have,
I'd never actually met
Simon McBurney, but uh,
that thought that he has at the
very end that in order to something
you need an active imagination. I think
it's kind of understating it really,
I think. And just stating
your house. How's that? Well,
let's just take the situation
we're in right now. Okay.
I'm sitting here in front
of you. We're about what,
three feet apart or something like that.
So when you look at me right now,
it takes actually the light
that's bouncing off my face,
a tiny bit of time to reach
your retina. But by the way,
I arrive upside down and
have your brain write me,
takes a little bit of
time for the sound of me.
This sound right now you think ha,
but the sound is to travel at
750 miles an hour for me to you.
Okay the rest to enter
that ear that you have,
it has to travel through those
hairs that you've got in your ear.
It has to turn into electricity.
It has to go to the place in your brain
where sounds lie and then the touch of
me,
if I were to touch you right now and have
to travel electrically to your brain,
that would take a little
time. God had the smell of,
suppose I put some licorice in my mouth.
I gone the smell of the
licorice coming out of my mouth.
That too would have to travel all
the way to your nose, up your nose,
into the place where smells lie,
and then your brain has to take all
these parts and pull them together into
this, this thing that you
think is going on right now.
Wait, let me get this straight. You're
saying that that this moment, yes,
and this one and this one,
yes, are hopelessly lost.
So when people say that you know you have
to live in the moment, to this moment,
the moment, the moment already just
happened. Or to put it another way,
it's a memory. Everything.
Everything is a memory.
Wow. So let's say we want
to ponder this moment.
This one you say has already happened
before it even had a chance to become this
moment. But let's say we want to
remember it later. What do we do?
It's interesting at this,
what's going to happen is you're
going to take the touch to the sound,
the smell, and everything that's
in your brain from that moment,
which is all sitting lodged in different
places and you're going to reassemble
it, pull it back together again.
Now, here's the interesting thing.
If 20 minutes from now
you are really hungry,
then the licorice member, the
licorice part of our discussion. Yup.
The licorice part will somehow loom a
little larger because you want to eat or
chew something.
How you're feeling in the moment that
you're remembering has a lot to do with
what you remember. So for that,
let's just take a simple a phrase like
Jack and Jill went up the hill to fetch a
pail of water, right? If you
want to recollect that phrase,
let's suppose you just had
a wonderful thing with Jill.
Now when you think of the rhyme,
when you reassemble it, Jack,
it'll go jack.
And he went up the hill
to fetch a pail of water.
Wait, see the, see the Jill thing is.
So I that instead you've just come from
an extraordinary hike where you have
gloriously climate spectacular
hill. So now you hear the thing.
And when you re assembled this time
yet you think Jack and Jill went up the
hill.
[inaudible]
I see the sudden now the hill nus
has got all the emphasis. I got it.
So you're always remembering
differently. Each time up,
depending upon how you feel. This
reminds me of sunny. We here,
let me play you this interview clip
every time you recall
something. You're doing so good.
I mean, it's amazing to me
that at such an early point,
the business of deconstructing puzzles,
which I guess is a lot of what we did,
uh, took on this very particular quality,
like this kind of razzle-dazzle of
anything could happen in the next second.
I don't know who's gonna
say the next thing,
but there's something beautifully organic
about it when it's done. Yeah. So,
uh, today we're selling [inaudible]
braiding 15 years of making radio
lab coming up after the break.
We're going to play the first
thing we ever podcasted.
It's not something you can get on iTunes
cause it fell off iTunes a long time
ago. But we're going to play
you the first [inaudible].
This is Lisa Kenney
calling from San Diego.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
This is Terry Badcock
limits in Newark, Delaware.
Radiolab is supported by dash
digital cash. This safe, reliable,
and instant way to send
money to anyone anywhere,
whether you're buying a coffee or
sending funds to another country.
Dash enables instant remittances
and payments for pennies.
Get discounts at hundreds of stores
and services by using dash today.
Dash is digital cash.
For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org slash Radiolab
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year.
Make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award-winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hey, we're back. Uh, so the
first episode we ever podcasted,
I don't know if it was
literally the first,
but it was among the first
few was an episode about time.
I do remember playing it to my wife who
I was always scared cause she was in new
your times reporter and I thought, oh
she'll never liked this kind of thing.
And she came out of the kitchen
and she said, I really like that.
And immediately I called through you call
me and you were like, oh you whisper.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's one of the, one
of the early modes where like maybe this
will work. Yeah. Again,
this is something that fell off
our podcast for ed years ago,
so probably very few
people have heard this.
You are listening to radio on New
York public radio, public radio,W
Y s
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
do you know this music? Trust me.
You've heard it your entire life.
[inaudible]
the reason you can't recognize it now
is because the composer born in 1770
intended for this moment that when
you're hearing to last two seconds
[inaudible]
caliber. Had he been a whale,
Beethoven might've written
his ninth symphony this way.
Changes that for us.
We're taking an instant,
we transpire over minutes and a
movement might last six hours.
That's in fact what this is.
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony digitally
stretched from its normal 60 some odd
minutes to last an entire day, 24 hours
and if you sit for the entire 24 hour
duration of the piece as people do from
time to time you realize that
this music is not simply slower.
The Sloane is unlocks
something in the original.
Maybe it was there all along and we
couldn't hear it. Play with the meter.
Music is mostly about meter after all
and the music has a different story to
tell a secret perhaps locked
up and signed through routine,
changed the routine and
make new discoveries.
That's what we'll do this hour.
We'll look at time so closely.
We'll discover new things about it.
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad up and Ron,
my guest tonight for the next hour to
help me wrestle with time is the science
correspondent, Robert Crow, which
of ABC News and Nova and Nightline.
How are you sir? I'm very well.
I like this bathing in Beethoven thing
you've got going on. It's cool, right?
Yeah. Actually at the end of the program,
we will be dropping in on a performance
that happened recently in San Francisco
where people listen to it over the
course of an entire day or day a day.
So where first, let's begin with a
guy who I think you'll find, well,
he thinks very deeply about time. In
fact, in a very general kind of way,
you could say he's time obsessed.
You've heard of the neurologist,
Oliver's hacks. Sure. The man who
mistook his wife for a hat. Yeah. Right.
And a weakness. So I
was over at his house.
This is me actually over
at his house right now.
Keep turning. Um, and
he told me this story.
I don't know whether this is relevant.
I had an odd experience some years ago.
In fact, in 1993 when I got a, um,
a message from my publisher,
which they had sent out to
various of their authors, uh,
for their 21st birthday,
the jubilee asking if we would like to
select a year from the previous 21 years
and write about it. Um, when I
got this message, I thought, well,
why don't I choose 1972, which was the
first of the years and it's a year,
which is, uh, um,
very vivid and important for me,
partly because it was the
year in which my mother died.
Partly it was the a in which I completed
awakenings. And these two events,
uh, were coupled in some ways.
I was actually in the car
when I got this message.
I picked it up on a car phone and I was
driving up to Canada and I had a tape
recorder with me. So I, um,
I spoke 1972 aloud and by that time,
uh, I thought, well, why stop, why
don't I do in 1973 as well? Um,
by the time that long in 72 take,
did you get to Montreal or we used to
[inaudible] 72 probably took about, about,
um, half an hour. Well, by the time
I got to the Canadian border, um,
I was up to 1987. Um, and um,
I did in fact make an extra loop so
that I could complete things. Um,
however it turned out that the,
the most recent years in the
late eighties and the nineties,
I did not apparently have
such detailed memories of,
and they seem subjectively shorter.
So time, I guess we all know
this is a very plastic thing.
It's swollen enriched some of the time
and it's like flacid and other times.
But because Oliver is so inquisitive,
such an investigator at heart,
all his life,
he's looked inside things and
beginning when he was a 10, 11,
12, he wanted to get inside time.
I had, I had, um, lots
of boyish interests, uh,
and um, you know, these
pre-adolescent interests, you know,
they will took a beating when I
became an adolescent, but, uh,
but one of them was chemicals
and I had a chemistry laboratory.
One of them was photography and I had
dark room and cameras and one of them was
plants.
And in particular my mother was very
fond of firms and the garden was full of
firms. I love the way in which the, um,
the curled up fiddleheads or
cruisers or firms would unfurl.
And it was almost as if time was sort
of rolled up inside of them as if time
itself unfilled, but when
couldn't actually see this,
they were pets take a a day or two
to do this and I wanted to see it.
It made me think of these Christmas
things. One, we're blowing book,
these are paper trumpets,
which would unfold. And so I,
uh,
set up my camera on a tripod and at
least in the daytime I couldn't take
pictures at night. I didn't have a flash.
Then I took a series of pictures every
hour or so of the fun and that showed
these rapidly by putting them
together in a flip book and this way,
then what took a day or two or several
hours to happen was compressed into
several seconds.
So the compression of time
photographically fascinated me,
yes to if Oliver sacks can make
a baby from unfurl. Robert,
how about this radio producer,
Tony Schwartz can do the same
thing with his baby niece.
What exceptance sound, oh,
here's sped up for your appreciation
is Nancy Schwartz from birthday
[inaudible]
you know what that is? What's that?
That is if you repair what you've just
heard is a parent clock up parent clock.
That's kind of cool
cause the kid gets older.
You can't deny the fact that you must
be getting older too when your son has
hair on his legs. I thought, Oh man,
I'm getting old. But this is true.
This is how the whole world works.
I think it's a, it's a, everything
is a clock I guess. Yeah. By the way,
that was Nancy grows up in the audio
flip book recorded and arranged by the
great radio producer Tony Schwartz.
Thanks to him and to Smithsonian folkways
recordings and also to you Mr Rodmel
Cro, which for joining me today
on our program to talk about time.
So here's my question.
If we've got an example of what
you just called a parent clock,
you've got other kinds of time, you
know like PR, like personal time,
getting out of bed, time going to
sleep. Most of the existence really
time was measured by, oh it's lunchtime,
it's wake up time, right time to milk.
The cow time events are
task time, tasks, times.
How do we get from task and
personal time to clock time. Oh,
that's interesting.
Let's go back to the 18
hundreds and imagine a guy,
we'll call him all zoll Tom True Bogan
zeal to a hundred lawyers living in
Sandusky, Ohio. And suppose
the old time wants to know,
you know what time it is.
Okay, so if Zoltan walked into,
say bigsbys tavern and asked,
I missed the big speaker,
I trouble you put the time, eight right
in front of you. You see these pocket,
it's built by my nephew,
not the smartest boy in the,
well it says 33 minutes past
the hour. Is that right?
Of course it's right. However,
if Zoltan instead of
going into the tavern,
had he gone at the exact same
moment into the bank building,
how can I help you sir?
And I wondered if you could show me
the time to read minutes past the hour.
Is he right though? Easy to right
or at that very same moment.
Suppose instead of going to the tablet
of the bank, he'd gone to the hotel.
Can I hear you? Can you tell me
the time? Yes, of course. My,
my time piece has pain,
which is actually initially the
style actually each 19 past the hour.
So at the tavern it's 33 past the
hour at the hotel, 19 past the bank,
three past. What time is it really
in Sandusky? That's the question.
The answer is there was no
official time in Sandusky. Huh?
What do you mean there's
no official time and send?
There wasn't any non 1850 government and
at the time really all there were were
clocks. So in Ohio in the 1850s,
you'd have as many times as
they were clocks in the town.
So there was no reason. And you
think about it to synchronize it,
your clock and my clock were four minutes
or 10 minutes different in Sandusky in
1850s. Who cares until
the railroad changed every
one once the wheel road clean.
If Zoltan wanted to take, uh, how about
the uh, three or three to Cleveland.
Okay. If you wanted to take
the field, who you believe in,
how would he know when it
was three Oh three. Oh,
I see where you're going with this.
If you went by the bank's clock,
he'd arrived a half hour ahead of
time. If you went by the hotel clock,
he'd arrived in the nicotine.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
And if you went by the taverns clock,
oh no. [inaudible]
so for the sake of their business,
read the railroads created railroad time
and began putting up clocks of their
own. It makes sense. And because the
railroads were so important, right?
I mean the tavern would, you have to get
it's beer deliveries from the railroad.
And I guess the banks would have to get
their cash from the railroad and the
hotel would have to get their guests
when they're at road. So it gradually,
real time
becomes everybody's time.
Huh.
So what happened to local time? Will
local time disappeared. Really? Yeah.
If local time means that
when it's noon in Sandusky,
the sun is directly over your head.
By 1880 that wasn't true anymore.
Oh,
the railroad had instructed Sandusky
that from now on it's noon would be 20
minutes later. So that could
fit into the railroad schedule.
So they moved noon over 20 minutes
and they were protests about this.
I put it to you ladies and
gentleman. Oh, Noonan, shut up.
[inaudible]
so in all seriousness,
people fought against this.
They rebelled against the railroads. Oh,
there were time wars in certain towns
where part of the town would go to
railroad time.
But the other part would determinately
stick with the what used to be local time
and they'd have different
times in the town. Wow.
It's almost like as a personal freedom
issue because time in a way represents
your own identity and they didn't
want to give up their identity to the
railroad. Not at first,
but in the end, Sandusky.
And then every other town eventually
conformed to railroad time.
And that is how time became
standardized. Time became zoned.
Time became clock reference. And
you ask somebody, what time is it?
They don't say, you know, oh
it's bedtime or it's lunchtime.
They don't look up at the side. They
look at a clock standard and the real,
that break pick of the other
time, one off every 60 minutes,
tweet every 12 hour tour of both
relentless hands, turning off Carload.
Lots of time.
There's an interesting
connection to explore here.
And it has to do with horses.
Horses, horses.
Okay. Alright. You mentioned
railroad companies.
It just so happens that the owner
of the biggest railroad company,
Leland Stanford, you know Stanford
University University, that right. He was
really into speed and he owned a
really fast horse and the horse,
his name was oxidant oxidant. I
know, I remember that story goes.
This horse was the subject
of a gentleman's bet. Well,
there was no gentleman's bet. It's a myth.
Danford so far as we know was not a
betting man. That's Rebecca Solnit.
She would know.
She wrote a book about this called river
of shadows and the focus of her book is
the solver of the bed. Oh, look at
her. It was, it was an argument.
There's no evidence that there
was money on it. In any case,
this argument amongst Stanford and
his railroad buddies sent it around.
The following question.
When a horse gallops,
do all four of its feet leave the ground
at once when you think? I don't know.
I'm just not a question.
I would frankly every,
I was getting one but well at the time
it was a big question cause they had no
way of knowing cause the horses
moved faster than eyeballs can see.
So Leland Stanford one and to prove
that of course at all four feet off the
ground at one time and he was recommended
to try my bridge as the photographer
to capture this. Along comes
Edward Muybridge, the photographer,
if he could take a picture of the horse
at exactly the right instant could see
whether all four feet were off the ground
in solve the bed. Here's the problem.
Cameras in those days were very slow.
Fast exposure would be maybe
a second or several seconds.
My vision was going to push photography
to suddenly be able to capture motion in
a 500th of a second.
Otherwise you just got blur.
Imagine that first step out of the world
of a blur when Brechin stretched a wire
across the race track and attached it
to the shutter mechanism on his camera.
Oxidant the horse gallops
by trips. The wire
[inaudible]
which freezes the horse.
Nick gala steals him right
out of the flow of time.
Except my bridge doesn't
just take one photo.
He takes 24 c it place
24 cameras in a line,
one after the other with 24 trip wires
stretching across the racetrack and the
horse strip. Every one.
Yeah,
24 frozen and blurry running horses.
So what did, what did they see?
Well,
the pictures formed a series of a horse
running and some of those photos showed
oxidant yes, with all
four feet off the ground.
So the camera here unlocks a secret.
It let's just see something you could
never see before because this camera
essentially it stops time. Exactly.
Meanwhile it says Rebecca Bridge became
fascinated with learning more secrets of
time,
secrets, lacking signs, basic
human movements. A leap, a splash,
a walk of parallel, wet. Wow. Mundane.
But they're so enchanted when you
really pay attention to them. Yeah.
Bridge had photograph rushing water.
He was obsessed with water and his
landscape pictures. So he, obsessive.
Lee has people pour water, splash
water, pour water over themselves,
poor pictures of water,
pour water into glasses,
splash water out of
basins, bathe in water.
And you can see all these
droplets frozen in midair.
There's one particular photo, Robert,
where you see a sheet of water suspended
in the air, hovering over the splasher.
Kind of like a ghost. Hmm. Oh Wow. Anyhow,
take all those frozen moments and align
them one after the other and play them
back. And you've got flow
again, albeit artificial flow,
which we call movies.
[inaudible] movies are
good. Yeah. Yeah. But
the next time you're feeling stressed
out, you saved yourself. I'm stressed.
I need to go to a movie to relax. Well,
you should know that the technology that
made the movies is exactly the thing
which spin up the pace of modern
life, which stressed you out,
which led you to go to the movies.
What does that mean? What did,
what do you mean by that? Well,
one of the first ways movies were
used was to film factory workers doing
repetitive tasks and then find out how
to make those tasks more efficient.
So if I were pushing the lever,
maybe too slowly is this right?
They would find the guy who did it the
right way, film him, slow the film down,
and then use that to teach everyone
else. And then when World War II came,
this was not just now in
the cause of efficiency,
this was a life or death matter.
Cause this is how you beat Nazis.
All the scientific devices
of chronology. I'm a,
the manufacturing time in
all hands means victory.
And all hands must be as we learned
with our hands, hadn't [inaudible]
or there's a whole nother
way to think about this.
Time can be a weapon in battle or it
can be the most sensuous and subtle and
natural thing in the world.
And I learned about this from a book by
Jay Griffiths called a sideways look at
time. Let me just take a
stop here at the clocks.
Even though you don't like clocks because
there's so many cool clocks in your
book. First of all, there's a spice clock.
Yes, we're used to clocks,
which you can see when it's
really dark and it's seen.
And you can see that you've just woken
up at two 35 and you really didn't want
to wake up at two 35 but of
course for a long time, you know,
in the night you don't have a
way of seeing what the time is.
And so somebody invented a spice cock
so you could taste your way through the
nights. So there would be
maybe kind of, you know,
cinnamon for about one o'clock
in Turmeric for two o'clock.
You're sitting there in bed and you
stiff the time. Oh, you could taste it
right. How about the clock of birds?
This is the [inaudible] supporters. This
is lovely. The clearly people
apart when you're getting,
they have what they call
a clock of birds. Um,
and that certain birds like the um, New
Guinea fryer bird and the hooded butch,
but when they sing in the mornings,
the children are taught to understand
that that's a signal to get up and leave
the house.
When those birds sing,
that late afternoon calls,
that's a signal to the
children to go back home.
Just a forest in the central highlands
in Papua New Guinea. I've been,
that is a very, very difficult
place to be in once it's dog.
And that the children would need to know
at what time to start heading for home.
[inaudible] now, how about it's 1751
Carl Linnaeus famous catalog.
Categorize her of everything. Yes.
Our clock. What do you make it?
A flower clock so that you could,
you could see by the blooming of
different flowers. Um, what time?
It was some kind of something that blooms
in the morning and then folds up like
a morning.
Glory would be there in the morning and
then in the evening and evening primrose
would come out. Yeah.
These are all plants that opened
for an hour or two and then close.
So if you're walking by and you see a
blush of let's say pink, then you know,
oh, it must be in the morning. Or
if you say blush of Privilege, Oh,
it must be lunchtime or whatever
it is. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
That's by the way, very, very good
gardening to be able to do that. Yes,
isn't it? Isn't it? And connected to that.
There's also the Andaman forests and the
Andaman islands in the Indian nation.
Um, that people have a sense calendar,
which I find the most
beautiful idea because some,
what it was is a way of kind of describing
the months by the sense of certain
fruits and flowers.
Okay. Time at time is everywhere
in nature. What I put,
one of the things I wanted to do with
the hope book was to say, you know,
we think of time thing to do with
clocks. In fact, for most of the world,
for most of history time has been
absolutely embedded in nature in some
beautiful ways.
Thanks Robert. [inaudible] Robert Krulwich
tonight we'll be back in a moment.
You're listening to radio on New
York public radio, public radioW
and why
[inaudible]
so that was a chunk of the
first thing we ever podcast.
It was a show about time and
it's in honor of our 50th birthday. And
because there's, it's funny, Robert,
like there's, we just looked at the
[inaudible] at our RSS feed recently,
which access is, um, it's a, I
don't know what it stands for,
but it's the thing that like feeds iTunes.
So when you go on iTunes and you see
all the episodes, you sort of see what,
what's there and there's some limit
that's that iTunes places on the number of
items that you can have in the feed. Oh.
And there I think it's a hundred or 150
or something.
And we realized like 150 early
episodes have fallen off the feed.
Oh really? Yeah.
We were a backlist like at random
house that would be like Hemingway and
Fitzgerald had fallen
onto the floor. Exactly.
So like these huge number of
old episodes have fallen off.
And I started looking at that list and
on that list are some episodes that are
weirdly relevant now at a whole bunch
that are just completely not relevant.
And, uh, I was like, I, you know,
I think I want to pull some of
those back into the flow and, uh,
because it'll give us a chance to like
sorta just reframe them and rethink about
them and update them.
And sometimes the science gets
old and needs to be updated,
but sometimes design gets refreshed by
something that's happening in the real
world. Yeah. Something, it gets
on a certain urgency. Yeah. So I,
so what the plan would
be is maybe, you know,
in the coming months we would go way
back for us, which is like 14, 13,
15,
12 years back and resurrect things and
throw them out and see who wants to take
a smack at them now and whether
there's things have changed. Yeah.
And whether they, whether they're
more interesting or, or utterly wrong.
Now we're all wrong in a fascinating
way. Yeah. That kind of thing. Yeah.
That's the advantage of getting old as
you can. That's true. Yeah. That's true.
You can play with your memories. Exactly.
You can not be a rabbit. There
you go. All right, well that was,
that was something,
and thanks for listening.